welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss an avatar the way of water is the
second of James Cameron's Avatar
pentology whatever five movies is and
based on early buzz it sounds like this
sequel has a chance of repeating the
2009 film's uncanny spell of drawing in
unlikely moviegoers Like Moths To Flames
or really like Ewa to Jake sunnis so
that a good number of you may end up
seeing this movie this holiday season
despite seeing the first avatar maybe
once 13 years ago vaguely remembering
liking it before some snob told you that
you're stupid and what you like isn't
actually good but like Ryan Gosling
secretly loving that Papyrus font admit
it some part of you has long to return
to Pandora and straddle an Acron half
naked as we will likely see in the way
of water the world of Avatar is actually
far denser than whatever you may
remember about ponytail so in this video
I'm gonna explain everything you need to
know going into the second Avatar film
what happened in the first Avatar and
more broadly the mythology that fuels
and binds all of these characters the
2009 Avatar film follows Jake Sully's
Sam Worthington a quadriplegic Marine in
year 2154 who joins mission to a distant
moon named Pandora which has a CO2 heavy
atmosphere that requires oxygen masks
Pandora is being mined for a mineral
called unobtainium by the RDA that's the
resources development Administration a
private Corporation even more powerful
than Earth's governments but Pandora is
populated by the humanoid Navi who share
a bond with the planet's animals and
plant life called sahelu Jake replaces
his dead brother Tommy to participate in
an avatar program in which the RDA has
developed artificial Navi fused with the
DNA of human Pilots which is why these
big blue things look vaguely like Sam
Worthington and Sigourney Weaver This
research team is led by Dr Grace
Augustine Sigourney Weaver's character
who studies the navi and the whole
Botany of Pandora and she seeks a
diplomatic relationship masking the
rda's true objective to relocate the
navi so they can drill their sacred
lands Jake gets separated from Grace's
Group by running into a hammerhead
titano theater and then fleeing a
thanator but is saved from a pack of
Viper wolves by nitiri that's Zoe sultan
who nearly kills Jake before an a was
like hey come on duh natiri sees the A1
that surrounds Jake is a sign that he
should be inspected by her mother and a
spiritual leader of the omatakaya clan
Mott so these navies see the avatars as
freaks but since Jake is the first one
they've met with a warrior background
they decide to study him and teach them
their ways this makes Jake super
valuable to Grace as well as to Parker
self-rageous Giovanni Ribisi the
corporate administrator for the RDA
mining operation and to Colonel Miles
korich Stephen Lang head of security who
tells Jake to spy on the navi for him
promising to restore his legs for him
back on Earth but Jake falls in love
with interior as he grows into becoming
a member of the tribe bought him with an
econ learning how that sahelu connects
the full biosphere via a chemical
electrical Network and Jake ends up
hooking up with natiri but Selfridge
mows down a sacred spiritual growth and
sends courage to strike home tree Jake
and Grace try to convince the navi to
evacuate but the navi feel betrayed and
they stand their ground against the
human assault but it kills natiri's
father and wrecks the tree Grace is shot
in the escape and she ends up and a
failed attempt to transfer her
Consciousness to her Navi body at the
Tree of Souls Jake ends up bondingly the
mythologize to rook and returns to the
navi as their Champion uniting the clan
and leading the navi in a battle in the
Hallelujah mountains or aramalusing the
Rocks suspended in a flux Vortex due to
the meissner effect that scrambles even
aircraft's navigation meanwhile the
Pandora and Wildlife comes to the navier
gorge suits up in an amp extra skeleton
and attacks Jake's human body but
interior ends up killing courage and she
and Jake Suli I see you each other for
the first time humans are expelled from
Pandora and Jake's Consciousness is
transferred to his Navi body via the
Tree of Souls mirroring the opening shot
of the movie his Navi eye opens so this
brings us to the second film Avatar the
weight of water this film catches up
with the Sully family several years
after this Jake and the Tyrion now have
three biological Navi children their
oldest son ate yam their second son
Loach and their daughter tuktiri AKA
took they have an adopted human son
miles spider sakuru a teenager who was
born on Hell's Gate the base from the
first film they also haven't adopted
Navi teenage daughter Kiri Sigourney
Weaver playing this teenager rebooting
it with some of the memories of Grace
Dad I know you think I'm crazy but I
feel her I hear her heartbeat
she's so close so some weird stuff is
going on here especially when you
consider that they're also bringing back
Stephen Lang as gorich who has been
resurrected by the RDA as a recombinant
these are new avatars embedded with the
memories of humans the same goes to Matt
Gerald's character who died in the 2009
film but is returning as the
recombinants Corporal Lyle Wayne Fleet
now the reason these videos are so
detailed folks is that I really just
spend all my time consuming content but
the problem is a lot of these streaming
platforms don't always have access to
100 of the content that I know that they
have which is why I always boot up my
streaming platforms with expressvpn
because using Netflix without expressvpn
is like going to a restaurant and only
being allowed to eat food on the left
side of your plate that's a lot of good
food on that right side that you're
missing out on Netflix has thousands of
shows and films that you can't access
based on your location without
expressvpn you are missing out so thanks
to expressvpn for sponsoring this video
expressvpn lets you change your online
location so that you can access all the
shows you want get access to all that
blocked content open yourself up to
whole new libraries of content without
having to pay for a new streaming
service just this week I used it to
watch The Studio Ghibli films I just
switched my location to the UK refresh
the page and I could watch to do Ghibli
films for free our European friends can
do the reverse and enjoy all of our us
only content I just like how easy
expressvpn is to use no confusion no
wasted time and the whole thing runs
fast you just fire up the app and
connect with just one click it is the
top rated VPN provider rated number one
by tech radar so find out how you can
get three months of expressvpn for free
by visiting expressvpn.com new rockstars
or clicking the link in the description
below but it sounds like the RDA is
using a technological process their form
of playing guide whereas Kiri seems to
be more of a natural reincarnation via
the AWA something grace actually hinted
at in the 2009 film it's a network
Global Network and the navi can access
said they can upload and download data
Memories the way of water will feature
Jake and Terry and their family
relocating to the metcaina ocean clan of
Pandora which is led by tonawari and his
wife ronal who's played by Kate Winslet
these aquatic Navi have adaptations of
Latter arms to paddle with and thicker
more muscular tails for steering
underwater Edie Falco is also joining
the cast playing General Francis Ardmore
the RDA Commander I have not seen the
film yet but it does look like it's
going to sit around a custody dispute
over spider while deepening the
spiritual lore over how souls are passed
through nature remember though while the
AWA is considered the seeds of the
Sacred Tree by the navi AWA herself is a
navi goddess a deity that did not
originate on Pandora Pandora itself is a
moon orbiting the gas giant of
polyphemus in the system of Alpha
Centauri a Pandora is rich in
unobtainium and in fact the aromalous
thing floating mountains magnetic field
may actually be caused by unobtaining
deposits by the way unobtainium is a
real world engineering joke that comes
up as a kind of Trope in sci-fi like in
the 2003 movie Decor James Cameron also
hinted at a similar hypothetical Miracle
metal in his Terminator films a room
temperature superconductor that was used
to create Skynet it also looks like the
mets kaina has their own version of
these floating formations that line up
with polyphemus on the horizon but where
did the Ewa come from if not from
Pandora where you're talking about a
spiritual hive mind that spans planets
suggesting that the whole ecosystem of
Pandora despite its unique nature is
actually something fuel to protected by
an extraterrestrial source and when you
look into the AWA Dogma it's really
known for the Three Laws you shall not
set stone upon Stone neither shall you
use the Turning wheel nor use the medals
of the ground basically all three of
these laws are prohibiting technology
from forming specifically weapons
technology so in this Slide the AWA does
feel like an anti-technology spirit that
is driven away from planets when those
planets begin to industrialize like
imagine if James Cameron were to go nuts
and try to link this to the aliens
mythology the AWA would be the
mythological enemies to the engineers
whenever civilization takes its
Promethean Leap Forward the A1 depart in
a diaspora seeking to bless and preserve
a purer more innocent race while dooming
that industrialized planet to inevitably
destroy itself in that sense yeah maybe
the AOL was on Earth at some point until
Stanley Kubrick's Apes found that
monolith and messed it all up so here we
go I think that covers the basics of
what you need to know ahead of Avatar
the way of water with a bit of gospel of
Boss worked in there so you can sound
like the biggest nerd in that AMC Lobby
afterward you can follow me on Tick Tock
Hive Instagram and Twitter at a boss
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]